t
a été stoppé par le crash de
1929. Je vous invite à faire la
visite du château.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un bijou patrimonial de
style Beaux-Arts, des escaliers
finement sculptés, des fresques
peintes par de grands maîtres.
Le Château Dufresne
a été construit en pleine
Première Guerre mondiale
par les frères Dufresne,
des bourgeois canadiens français
établis dans l'actuel quartier
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve.
MANON LAPOINTE, directrice gén.
conservatrice, Château Dufresne
- Ce sont des gens qui ont voulu
implanter une bourgeoisie
francophone dans l'est de
Montréal, alors que le secteur
ici était presque rural.
Et en s'inspirant des grands
courants urbanistiques,
ils ont voulu implanter
une ville modèle, une ville
où il fait bon vivre.
- Le Château Dufresne est l'un
des 14 musées qui participent
cette fin de semaine au premier
Festival d'histoire de Montréal.
Le château de Ramezay
y figure aussi; un autre lieu
exceptionnel chargé d'histoire.
ANDRÉ DELISLE, directeur général
Musée du Château Ramezay
- Cette année, on célèbre
le 125e anniversaire
de l'existence du Musée.
Si on en a fait un musée,
c'est parce qu'il avait
un riche passé. C'est, comme on
dit souvent, un témoin de bien
des moments de notre histoire.
De Claude de Ramezay, gouverneur
de Montréal en 1705, en passant
par la présence américaine en
1775, la compagnie des Indes,
Lord Elgin et bien d'autres.
- Ici, on proposera
des activités spéciales
toute la fin de semaine.
- Toute la programmation
a été élaborée sur une grille
d'expérience de l'histoire.
Goûter l'histoire, jouer,
rire l'histoire, témoigner
l'histoire.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'histoire n'est pas
quelque chose de figé;
elle est en mouvement.
L'Afromusée, qui ouvrira
officiellement ses portes dans
quelques semaines, se joint
aussi au Festival et demande
aux internautes de participer
à une carte interactive en
indiquant des lieux importants
de l'histoire des communautés
afro-montréalaises.
GUY MUSHAGALUSA CHIGOHO, prés.
Espace Mushagalusa, Afromusée
- C'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment ouvert, c'est-à-dire...
c'est de donner la parole aux
Africains, aux afro-descendants,
mais aussi à leurs alliés ou
les personnes qui s'intéressent
à ça, et il y en a beaucoup.
- Que ce soit pour découvrir
l'histoire des soeurs
hospitalières...
♪ ♪ ♪
... ou comprendre l'évolution
de la rue Amherst, devenue
Atateken, le Festival d'histoire
de Montréal, c'est plus de
30 activités en personne
et en ligne pour célébrer
la richesse de notre histoire.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪